we get terrified just watching stranger
things especially the fourth season the
actors who had to perform those freaky
scenes had it much worse off and we've
got the scoop on just how brave they had
to be to make these scary moments happen
number one run max run
yeah it was pretty intense no kidding we
were freaked out just watching it but to
be performing that emotionally
exhausting scene live the fact that they
spent so long doing it definitely didn't
help that was shot over i don't know how
many i think it might have been a week
that we spent on that while the set
wasn't nearly as big as what it looks
like and sadie sink filmed in a smaller
more controlled environment without
details like the vines and such it was
all just enough to freak her out and
while it wasn't fun for her it was great
for the cameras number two
sometimes the scariest creatures are
just below our noses we're talking
bullies that's right as scary as vechna
and the demogorgon creatures of vol 4
are there is still something frightening
about the meanness of a bully and just
how cruel they can be a lot of the
horror comes from the humans in the
story the darkness within all of us
we've seen some real mean-spirited
people in this show and the fact that
people can actually be that hurtful
makes it that much scarier number three
this was a one-shot wonder for real this
should feel
real-time and viscerally connected this
one-shot shootout battle made for a
whole lot of planning it was going to be
hard it was going to be near impossible
one intense choreo session that saw the
director playing everyone's parts led to
a scene that would be easy for the
performers to act terrified during i do
believe that the best way to feed my
actors energy is by giving them energy
if we were those actors we would have
been okay with just a bit less energy
number four
the demogorgon is back bigger and badder
than ever would we expect anything less
from this team let's let this thing
loose and see what it can do and that
they did the sequence was so intense to
shoot they actually had to break it down
into three different parts meaning the
torture went on much longer than the
performers would have liked the stunt
team that performed this wild sequence
are trained professionals and have done
freaky stunts before but this scene was
next level swinging upside down wildly
definitely wouldn't be top of our list
either
number five this is the stuff that
nightmares are made of not like that my
goal is to make children not be able to
sleep that's what he says but the show
well it seems to indicate otherwise it's
going to be very exciting very scary
we've seen flash dear monsters before
but with vecna and we wanted something
that was much more sentient when millie
bobby brown first came face to face with
jamie campbell bauer and all his makeup
the actress was totally shook so
terrified that she just burst into tears
and sobbed uncontrollably we can't
imagine who wouldn't be freaked out by
vechna now we have an emotionally
invested motivated and revenge desiring
character
number six this wasn't a casual swim
yeah seeing steve dive so deep is freaky
but what's even more terrifying is the
fact that it was the actor himself
performing that stunt the place of his
nightmares was the giant water tank it
was in a big convention center in
atlanta luckily joe kiri had been
prepping and had anticipated swimming
for the show in the first season and in
the script they're like yeah you're
gonna be a swimmer and while it took
four seasons to literally dive in
kyrie's prep helped him for sure but it
didn't take away all the nerves of
filming such an intense sequence
underwater getting to do that sort of
stuff is like true movie magic number
seven it got real cold poor david
harbour went through the ringer filming
hopper's escape in russia since he had
to immerse himself right into the tough
stuff for a lot of it i'm running
shoeless and it's really not pleasant
the physical aspect was not fun at all
but what really shook the actor was how
much it affected his psyche it was
brutal like uh physically in that way
and it was also kind of brutal
emotionally we've got a feeling he
wouldn't want to go through that again
number eight the darkest season so far
that is season four has not disappointed
season four it was let's go nightmare in
elm street let's go hellraiser and now
that the actors were a bit older they
weren't worried about pushing them as
much so things got intense for the first
time for them it's like it's really we
want it to be really scary so what
better way to get those terrified
reactions than by actually terrifying
the cast let's just push this and try to
be as scary as possible and put them in
the middle of a true horror film
balancing the comedy with the horror was
key for this season making the big
clashes and vibes even more evident it
felt like right to go darker
number nine
she spun and she spun and then well she
nearly puked when it came time to film
the sequence that sees eleven falling
into billy's memories the actress had no
choice but to perform the freaky stunt
leaving her totally nauseous and gagging
physically it was exhausting and feeling
all that while filming content that's
supposed to be intense well we can
understand if she had some trouble
sleeping afterwards number 10.
baths are supposed to be relaxing but
not in this show can anyone blame
francesca real for being horrified while
filming this scene well the pool was
scary for a few reasons the actress
shared that i hate any body of water
that has a black bottom and this pool
you guessed it had a black bottom but
she wasn't alone in the pool no no real
shared they had this amazing mechanism
that attached to my foot and whenever i
was ready i would go down underwater and
the mechanism would tug me down
yeah we are not so sure we'd call that
mechanism amazing more like something
that could potentially drown you
number eleven
nothing about this sounds fun we're
throwing back to season two and the
attempts to get rid of the monster
attached to will and to say was
traumatic is putting it lightly schnapp
tried to remain professional throughout
the process but the struggle was real he
explained there were so many angles and
shots that they had to do for each shot
like you have to give it your all so
every angle every different shot it was
just constantly screaming okay so we can
conclude the experience of filming this
scene was equal parts terrifying and
exhausting number 12
say it ain't so
the reaction will byers as mom was
having on the show dealing with the loss
of will was pretty close to what noah
schnapp's actual mom experienced when
the duffer brothers played quite the
cruel and dark joke on her the
prosthetic will body that's used as a
fake in the first season was
terrifyingly realistic so we can
understand why schnapp's actual mom was
shook when she first saw it fortunately
she found the joy in it soon enough and
wound up taking photos with the dummy
number 13.
being trapped underwater is usually
terrifying the nerves we feel just
thinking of all of eleven's time spent
in the tank facing terrifying images
every time are real so we can only begin
to imagine the kind of nightmares milly
was having since she was actually
filming underwater with only a sea trek
helmet in place that allowed her to
breathe if she weren't afraid of
drowning before we wouldn't be surprised
if she was after this number 14.
if you know you know
i'm terrified
demogorgons are terrifying we know that
for sure but for toddlers that were
hanging around on set for the first
season well they were fully unsettled
even millie was freaking out on the
inside i'm frightened about everything
since they did have to get through
filming one of the grown-ups sunset
tried to help the actors through it by
telling them it was the same monster
they knew from monsters inc a surprising
comparison but it worked for the kids
number 15.
they didn't know what hit him these
young actors faced their fears time and
time again in the early years but for
season 4 to truly frighten them well
it's not something they anticipated
definitely exceeded my expectations with
how scary they could go but just how
scary would they say it is
oh definitely an 11. yeah we'll stay on
this side of the screen those scenes
brought the actors some serious fear and
with good reason which scene would you
be most scared to film